können die alliierten russlands
wichtigstes exportgut blocken und könnte
die welt ohne russisches erdöl auskommen
auch gepasst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in letzter zeit gab es viel über erdgas
geredet weil europa extrem abhängig
davon ist aber die wahrheit ist dass
russland in erster linie ein großer
erdölexporteur ist um euch eine
vorstellung zu geben 2021 exportierte
russland rohöl und öl erwartet benzin
diesel kerosin halbfinale und so weiter
im wert von rund 180 milliarden dollar
das ist dreimal so lukrativ wie seine
erdgas exporte mit denen es etwa 55
milliarden dollar verdiente
[Musik]
im jahr 2021 exportierte russland an
jedem tag des jahres durchschnittlich
etwa 4,5 millionen barrel rohöl und etwa
drei millionen barrel raffinierte
produkte diesen mengen war das land nach
saudi arabien der zweitgrößte exporteur
des schwarzen goldes weltweit übrigens
gegen sage und schreibe 70 prozent
dieser hohe exporte nach europa und in
die vereinigten staaten
dieses öl meine lieben personalpolitik
zuschauer haben die usa nun ins visier
genommen um die angeschlagene russische
wirtschaft vollständig zu zerschlagen
ich betone das weil es in diesem punkt
oft viel verwirrung gibt in den medien
wird manchmal gesagt dass eine blockade
wurde ein bahnhof russisches öl bedeuten
würde dass eine alternative quelle
gefunden werden müsse die die welt mit
etwa 11 millionen barrel pro tag
versorgen könnte aber das ist nicht wahr
[Musik]
russland zieht jeden tag etwa elf
millionen barrel öl aber ein großer teil
davon wird im inland verbraucht um der
russischen wirtschaft einen schweren
schlag zu versetzen wäre es noch nicht
einmal notwendig die gesamten exporte zu
ersetzen es würde ausreichen einen teil
davon vom markt zu nehmen bedenkt bitte
dass 40 prozent aller russische
staatseinnahmen direkt vom öl und gas
export abhängen
[Musik]
aufgrund russlands brutalen krieg gegen
die ukraine gibt es jedoch keine dieser
gewissheiten mehr alles kann sich ändern
ursprünglich schlossen die gegen
russland verhängten sanktionen den
energiesektor aus einschließlich der
bankgeschäfte die gekauft und verkauft
dieser rohstoffe ermöglichen
dies bis zum beispiel bei der gast paul
anka fall dem drittgrößten kredit ist
des landes das auch für die
transaktionen des russischen gasriesen
gazprom zuständig ist diese bank wurde
weder vom system noch von der
transaktion ausgeschlossen
viele banken raffinerien
ölgesellschaften und schiffseigner
reagierten jedoch auf die invasion und
die daraus resultierende internationalen
sanktionen indem sie sich bei geschäften
mit russischen unternehmen zu tätigen ob
es nun ein reputationsrisiko liegt haben
die angst dass die sanktionen ihnen
selbst schaden oder daran dass die
sanktion verlängert werden und es ihnen
nicht erlauben ihre rechnungen zu
begleichen tatsache ist dass der
einmarsch in die ukraine das russische
öl zu einem praktischen produkt gemacht
hat und das erklärte nachrichten wie
diese dann märz 2002 als sonst ich
stelle mir kein russisches öl und gas
mehr verkaufen und es kommt noch dicker
nach den angaben mehrere energieberatung
hatte russland nach dem überfall auf die
ukraine probleme für etwa 70 prozent
dass gerade geförderten oder schon auf
zehn befindlichen erdöls einen käufer so
senden
das ergebnis nach dem einmarsch in die
ukraine könnten die russischen ölexporte
in den ersten wochen um 35 prozent bei
rohöl und etwa 50 % bei verarbeiteten
produkten eingebrochen sein wir sprechen
hier von einem minus von bis zu 1,7
millionen barrel pro tag darüber hinaus
hat die zurückweisung des russischen öls
dazu geführt das ist billiger verkauft
werden muss so wird geschätzt dass das
öl aus dem uran mit abschlägen von mehr
als 25 us-dollar pro barrel auf den
markt kommt und
das ist noch nicht alles wenn der krieg
und der zyklus der sanktionen weiter
gehen steht laut dem astra university
institute eui star ist die echte gefahr
für russland darin dass ein exporte
weiter zurückgehen werden nach den
schätzungen dieses forschungszentrums
könnte es sich um 3,24 millionen barrel
pro tag handelt das sind etwa 50 prozent
der exporte wobei sowohl rohöl als auch
verarbeitete produkte berücksichtigt
werden und das wäre ein sehr schwerer
schlag für die russischen wirtschaft die
förderung schnell zurück zu fahren ist
technisch sehr schwierig es müsste
erstmal weiter gefördert dann und die
lagerkapazitäten wurde schnell
überquellen dann wäre russland sogar
gezwungen die produktion zu drosseln
indem es die bohrlöcher stilllegt
und das könnte verheerend sein denn es
ist gar nicht so einfach und billig die
förderung aus einem stillgelegten
bohrloch wieder aufzunehmen natürlich
könnte es auch sein dass russland
angesichts des knappen weltweiten
angebot sein öl doch irgendwie los wird
wenn auch zu stark reduzierten preisen
auch in diesem fall wäre der schlag zwar
erheblich aber nicht so verheerend
genau aus diesem grund suchen die
alliierten und vor allem die us
regierung händeringend nach
möglichkeiten die weltweite ölproduktion
so schnell wie möglich so steigern und
genau das etwa schlagzeilen wie diese
das weiße haus aktuell wir brauchen mehr
während die kraftstoffpreise in die höhe
schnellen der energieminister sagt die
nation befindet sich auf kriegsfuß
während kolumbien vor dem angebot will
das land für visual politik fans sieht
es so aus als würde die regierung von
joe biden alles daransetzen mehr öl zu
finden denn die suche nach neuen öl
vorkommen könnte es den alliierten
ermöglichen die mutter aller sanktionen
durchzusetzen ein vollständiges
öl-embargo gegen russland ein solches
embargo eine vollständige blockade die
selbst wenn sie sich nur auf rohöl und
nicht auf verarbeitete produkte
beschränken würde hätte das potential
russland ins mittelalter zurück zu
werfen das wäre schachmatt für das
regime putins und da kann er noch so oft
rubel für seine rohstoffe verlangen wird
sie einfach nicht bekommen nur stellt
sich die frage wie das weisse haus diese
neuen bezugsquellen für erdöl aus dem
hut zaubern möchte ist das alles
wirklich machbar was könnten die folgen
sein heute werden all diese fragen
beantworten und obendrein noch einen
gigantischen geheimdienst und
korruptionsskandal im energiesektor
offen reden schnallt euch also gut an es
wird heute wieder etwas wilder bevor
jedoch das alles tun müssen wir zuerst
noch joe biden wirtschaftspolitik einen
ordentlichen denkzettel verpassen angela
merkel war nicht das einzige
staatsoberhaupt das verdammt viel dafür
getan hat sein land so schlecht wie
möglich auf die herausforderungen der
zukunft vorzubereiten gut joe biden
hatte keine 16 jahre zeit dafür aber
auch in dem einen hat er ganze arbeit
geleistet deswegen musste er nach dem
einmarsch der russen in die ukraine
einen so großen schlenker vollführen
dass sich seine gesamte energie politik
als pure makulatur erwiesen hat und die
us wirtschaft ganz schön ins trudeln
brachte also aufgepasst
beides größter strategischer fehler
die energiewende hin zu sauberen
energiequellen zu beschleunigen das war
das wahlversprechen mit dem joe biden
die heimische öl industrie ins visier
nahm und nein in diesem fall handelt es
sich nicht um leere versprechen für
wahlkampfveranstaltungen ganz und gar
nicht als arbeit im weissen haus
angekommen war machte er sich an die
arbeit und begann ein dekret nach dem
anderen gegen die us ölindustrie zu
erlassen auf diese weise wollte der neue
präsident deutlich machen dass in
washington eine neue ära angebrochen war
wir dürfen da nicht übersehen dass wir
bei den usa lieber nichts geringeres als
den wichtigsten erdölproduzenten der
welt sprechen das ist also nicht mehr
witzig
[Musik]
denn am 20 januar 2021 unterzeichnete
joe biden ein umfassendes präsidiales
die kriegt diesen wurde die ölförderung
im arctic national wildlife refuge
gestoppt die genehmigung für die kiste
und xl pipeline mit der mär und
billigeres öl aus kanada eingeführt
werden sollte aufgehoben und die
regierungsbehörden wurden angewiesen
neue vorschriften zur eindämmung des
ölverbrauchs und der emissionen zu
prüfen wenig später am 27 januar wurde
durch eine weitere verfügung ein
moratorium erlassen das die
neuverpachtung von buntes eigenen land
und wasserflächen für die suche und
förderung von öl verbietet das ist
ziemlich gravierend denn fast 25 prozent
aktuellen und potenziellen us
förderungen hängen von feldern ab die
auf landflächen des bundes oder vor der
küste und damit war beiden noch lange
nicht fertig mit seinem feldzug gegen
die eigenen rohstoff industrie er wies
auch den innenminister an nach
möglichkeiten zu suchen die abgaben und
steuern für ölfirmen zu erhöhen und das
zu einer zeit in der andere ministerien
versuchten das verfügbare kapital und
die mittel für neue investitionen in
fossile brennstoffe zu reduzieren und
wenn man die verfügbaren mittel kürzt
wird natürlich auch die finanzierung
teurer erschwerend kommt hinzu dass sich
seither auch die erteilung von
genehmigungen für neue
explorationsbohrungen oder den bau neuer
pipelines oder zugriff straße zudem
fällt dann verlangsamt hat die anweisung
von oben war klar liegt ihnen so viele
steine in den weg dass sie darunter
ersticken
[Musik]
die bundesbehörde brauchen zum beispiel
etwa 140 tage um eine baugenehmigung zu
erteilen die texanischen behörden
braucht nur zwei und dieses ganze
massive maßnahmenpaket zusammengenommen
verfehlte sein ziel ganz und gar nicht
es hat nicht nur das potenziell angebot
an rohöl reduziert sondern vor allem
eine laute und klare botschaft an die
ganze us industrie gesagt es lohnt sich
nicht große summen in den ölsektor zu
investieren denn die regierung wird euch
das so hart bestrafen die vereinigten
staaten produzieren die etwa 11,6
millionen barrel pro tag das etwa 1,5
millionen barrel weniger als vor der
korona krise mit anderen worten ohne
dieses öl embargo mit dem die beiden
regierung das eigene land gelegt hat
während die erdöl- und benzinpreise
heute höchstwahrscheinlich viel
niedriger bedenkt bitte dass diese 1,5
millionen barrel mehr als 30 prozent
aller russischen rohöl exporte ausmachen
tja und jetzt wo putin die
klimaerwärmung als staatsfeind nummer
eins abgelöst hat legte das weiße haus
eine atemberaubende kehrtwende hin die
usa setzen die skifahrer industrie unter
druck alles zu tun um die ölkrise zu
lindern aber die frage die wir uns alle
stellen ist kann das russische öl
wirklich ersetzt werden wie genau will
die regierung beiden das erreichen hört
zu
[Musik]
wie kann man russisches öl verdrängen
das ist die millionen dollar frage jene
frage die alle pläne sagte mir putin
endgültig über den haufen werfen könnte
so etwas wie der finale schlag das weiße
haus und die anderen verbündeten
regierungen wollen nun so viel erdöl wie
möglich auftreiben damit sie das in baku
gegen russland umsetzen können wie genau
wollen sie das erreichen ist es wirklich
machbar um ihr ziel zu erreichen haben
sie eine strategie mit vier
handlungsvorschläge entwickelt und den
verbündeten regierungen auf den tisch
gelegt die erste davon hat genau
genommen mit der fracking industrie zu
tun
[Musik]
trotz aller hürden die das weiße haus
der ölindustrie in den weg gelegt hat
ist der produktionsrückgang in wahrheit
hauptsächlich auf den markt und die
industrie selbst zurückzuführen der
preisverfall zwischen den jahren 2015
und 2019 und dann deren der krone krise
war für die nordamerikanischen vergeben
unternehmen verheerend diese unternehmen
verloren dutzende und hunderte von
millionen und viele von ihnen gingen
schließlich pleite deshalb konzentrieren
sich die meisten von ihnen jetzt darauf
weiter weniger zu investieren oder die
hohen ölpreise dazu nutzen um geld zu
verdienen dividenden auszuzahlen und
aktien zurückzukaufen so groß war damals
der shop und zu groß ist noch immer die
angst dass sich heutige investitionen
nach einem erneuten einbruch wieder
nicht amortisieren würden tja so
funktioniert der markt nun mal er hat
ein gedächtnis auch wenn kann als zu
lang ist und angesichts der
explodierenden energiepreise die im zuge
der russischen aggression erleben müssen
wir uns die frage stellen was die us
regierung tun möchte um der industrie
die angst zu nehmen nun sie könnte damit
beginnen ihre haltung zu ändern die
genehmigungsverfahren zu vereinfachen
und günstige finanzierungen für neue
projekte zu ermöglichen und ein gesetz
namens jobs act abzuschaffen der jec
besagt dass nur schiffe unter us-flagge
waren zwischen us häfen transportieren
dürfen was auf den ersten blick wie eine
protektionistische maßnahme zum schutz
der heimischen wirtschaft aussieht
schadet ihr jedoch in wahrheit denn
diese regulierungsmaßnahme macht ist in
vielen fällen billiger ausländischen öl
importieren als heimisches öl zu kaufen
nach angaben der kalifornischen
energiekommission kann der transport von
erdöl aus dem golf von mexiko zum
beispiel 67 prozent teurer sein als die
einfuhr aus dem ausland allein durch die
abschaffung all dieser kontraproduktiven
maßnahmen könnte die nordamerikanische
produktion bis ende 2022 um mehr als
eine million barrel pro tag steigen
hierzu kommt die steigerung der fracking
produktion und ich weiß fracking klingt
in den ohren vieler erstmal nach risiko
und umweltverschmutzung allerdings aus
einem ganz anderen grund als die meisten
zu wissen glauben auch europa hat
eigentlich immense schiefergas
ressourcen und in den 2000er jahren
standen die großen energie firmen in
europa bereit das heimische gas zu
erschließen doch die ressourcen blieben
im boden der druck von klimaaktivisten
auch firmen und regierungen hat so
abkehr der investoren geführt die
exploration neuer öl- und gasfelder in
europa brachen auch in großbritannien
das über besonders reichhaltige
schiefergas was erstens verfügt und
nicht nur endlos auch viele
wissenschafts institute bejubelten
diesen trend aktienkurse von firmen die
bekanntgaben ihre förderung von gas öl
ausweiten zu wollen wir ihnen unter
druck offenbar fürchteten anleger
imageschäden in den niederlanden
forderte sogar ein gericht vom
energiekonzern shell seine co2
emissionen zu reduzieren was die
explorationen weiter bremste der große
widerstand gegen die erdgas und öl
förderung in europa und den usa machte
gas und öl aus russland immer
attraktiver
und dass die gigantischen förderanlagen
der russen wir reden überhaupt keinen
umweltstandards entsprechen müssen wurde
dabei geflissentlich ausgeblendet
europas zum beispiel drosselte seine
förderung konventionellen erdgases
radikal vor 15 jahren hatte es mehr gas
produziert als russland exportierte
mittlerweile exportiert russland dreimal
mehr erdgas als europa produziert ja und
wie es immer mehr ans licht kommt hat
der kreml seit mitte der 2000er jahre
massiv ensi aus umweltschutz bewegungen
und medien in europa und den usa
finanziert und unterwandert um eine ganz
bestimmte agenda durchzusetzen die
abhängigkeit und russischen rohstoffen
allein 82 millionen euro hat die
russische regierung an europäische
klimaschutz verbände über diesen deren
ziel es ist erdgasförderung in europa so
verhindert gazprom finanzierung wurde
bei unzähligen umwelt angeles gestellt
und auch beim atomausstieg hatte
gastraum ordentlich die finger im spiel
sprich es gab millionen dafür aus um
politiker und umweltverbände bei der
überzeugende öffentlichkeit unter die
arme zu greifen kernenergie sei etwas
schmutziges und gefährliches und
russisches gas sei etwas absolut super
sauberes die nato hat zum beispiel schon
seit jahren dass russland mit der
förderung gezielte propaganda versucht
europäische energieprojekte zu
diskreditieren vor allem fracking
projekte in europa zu behindern indem es
diese als umweltschädlich darstellt
viele experten rätselten baum plötzlich
gut organisierte umweltgruppen gegen
fracking in osteuropa auftauchten wo
russland seine energie verkaufte zuvor
aber keine sorgen wegen erdgasförderung
publik geworden waren dabei ist fracking
eigentlich eine seit jahrzehnten
erprobte technik die im laufe der zeit
immer zuverlässiger und schonender
geworden ist und mittlerweile
allerhöchsten westlichen umwelt
standards genügt so dass inzwischen kaum
noch probleme auftreten sogar die
ehemalige us außenministerin hillary
clinton berichtete in einer privaten
rede die von wikileaks veröffentlicht
wurde von sehr ungewöhnliche widerstand
gegen fracking sie sei eigentlich eine
unterstützerin aber sie sei sich sicher
dass die protestgruppen von den russen
finanziert sein das ganze ein sehr
starker weise daran wie die
westdeutschen friedensbewegung in den
1980 er jahren von der stasi finanziert
unterwandert und weitgehend gelenkt
wurde zb um in der westdeutschen
gesellschaft den anti amerikanismus zu
schüren und die akzeptanz
das totalitäre regime im osten zu
erhöhen und wenn damals von
konservativer seite davor gewarnt wurde
haben das viele als böse unterstellung
abgetan heute wissen wir jedoch aus den
stasi-akten dass dies alles auf
erschreckende weise real war ein ganzes
drittel aller stasi berichte der
hauptverwaltung aufklärung an das
politbüro stammt aus den vorstandsetagen
der gewerkschaften organisatoren des
krefelder abrüstungs abstatten allesamt
auf den lohnlisten der staatssicherheit
und die berühmte bewegung generäle für
den frieden war nichts als eine reine
stasi gründung hat ja die stasi-akten
lügen nicht es liegt daher nahe dass
sich der damals in der ddr stationierte
kgb-agent putin diese methoden gut
gemerkt und später zur durchsetzung
seiner energie agenda eingesetzt hat
klima und umweltschutzverbände
verbreiteten irreführendes filme von
orten an denen geweckt wird es wurde
trinkwasser gezeigt dass direkt aus dem
wasserhahn brannte es handele sich um
einen gasherd giftige gase und
chemikalien drangen aus der erde ganzen
landstrich hier waren angeblich
verseucht alle möglichen massenmedien
griffen diese szenen auf und störten
sich auch nicht daran dass diese
besonders aggressiv durch den
mittlerweile verbotenen russischen
sender russia today verbreitet wurden
dort wurden unter anderem frecken der
west firmen als kinderschänder
bezeichnet und es wurde
fälschlicherweise behauptet die
erdgasförderung würde bei kindern zu
krebs führen das ergebnis dass durch den
kreml finanzierten kampfes gegen die
erdöl und erdgasförderung in europa und
den usa ist für uns außerordentlich
ernüchternd
den klimaschutz hat es nicht gedient
erdgas wird trotzdem verbrannt es kommt
nur aus russland zu gunsten des erdgases
wurden kernkraftwerke abgeschaltet der
krieg in der ukraine verteuert gas
obendrein so dass die nachfrage nach
kohle und die co2 emissionen nur noch
stärker steigen das alles wäre nicht
passiert wenn unsere politiker nicht
diesen ganzen kreml finanzierten pseudo
umweltaktivisten auf den leim gegangen
wären und ich frage mich auch was
eigentlich unsere geheimdienste die
ganze zeit davon gewusst haben sollten
diese nicht auch irgendwie sicherstellen
dass belange von nationaler tragweite
nicht von ausländischen mächten
unterwandert werden wie zum beispiel die
versorgungssicherheit mit energie haben
sie nichts gewusst wurden sie von der
politik davon abgehalten diesen vorgang
nachzugehen oder haben sie die politiker
davon informiert und wurden dann von
ihnen einfach ignoriert all das sollte
jetzt aufgearbeitet werden im grunde
handelt es sich um einen weiteren
sicherheitspolitischen skandal über den
aktuell aber kaum gesprochen wird weil
dabei wohl zu vielen mächtigen akteuren
mit guten verbindungen in höchste
regierungskreise
auf die füße getreten dann müsste sie
alle werden also wohl weiter
unangetastet weitermachen können als
wäre nichts passiert nur halt ohne
russisches geld nun ja zumindest in
großbritannien gibt ist ein paar
anzeichen für android boris johnson
eröffnet als reaktion auf die ukraine
krieg die tür für frenkel niemand ist da
prüft alle optionen um eine neue
energiestrategie zu entwerfen und damit
wären wir auch schon beim zweiten paket
an handlungsvorschläge der usa
dieses betrifft nämlich ihre alten und
langjährigen partner die vereinigten
staaten wollen sich immer wieder aus dem
nahen osten zurückziehen aber am ende
kommen sie immer wieder zurück es
scheint fast wie ein fluch zu sein aber
auch jetzt stehen wir wieder an
derselben stelle wie immer wenn es um öl
geht müssen sie über den nahen osten
sprechen und insbesondere natürlich über
zwei länder saudi arabien und die
vereinigten arabischen emirate diese
länder gehören zu den wenigen
produzenten internet die langfristig
viel geld in die lagerung von erdöl und
den aufbau von reserven investieren das
heißt sie sind in der lage ihre exporte
sehr schnell zu steigern wenn ein
unerwartetes ereignis eintritt schaute
zum beispiel folgende daten an
[Musik]
wie ihr seht haben diese vier länder die
kapazität ihrer produktion
zusammengenommen um 4 millionen barrel
pro tag zu steigern was praktisch den
gesamten russischen export entspricht
selbst wenn sie nur 50 prozent kapazität
nutzen würden könnte es für moskau sehr
sehr eng werden nur die opec kann den
westen hessen ein russisches öl zu
ersetzen das problem ist dass die
aktuellen beziehungen zwischen weißem
haus und der saudi arabischen regierung
eher schlecht sind die regierung beiden
harris hat viel gemeinsames porzellan
zerschlagen dass ihr vorgänger shampoos
am angesammelt hatte aber auch hier
scheinen sie ihren kurs zu ändern und
bisher sieht es so aus als hätten die
vereinigten arabischen emirate bereits
begonnen darauf zu reagieren
zehnter märz 2022 vereinigte arabische
emirate bringen opec verbündete zur
erhöhung der ölproduktion und dann wären
da noch die erbitterten feinde mit den
washington jetzt offenbar einen
waffenstillstand an streckt das ist das
dritte aktionspaket langjährige visual
politik fans wissen natürlich schon
längst von dem die rede ist iran und
venezuela das land mit den größten
erdölreserven der welt wie viele videos
haben wir in der vergangenheit über
diese beiden durch die usa in den schlaf
benötigten rohstoff giganten gedreht ich
weiß es gar nicht mehr übrigens falls
ihr unseren kanal noch nicht abonniert
haben jetzt ist der beste moment dafür
und aktiviert wird auch das glöckchen um
keines unserer videos mit zu verfassen
und selbst zu bestimmen was er wann
sieht oder wollt ihr nur den youtube
algorithmus darüber entscheiden lassen
was ihr zu sehen bekommt und was nicht
aber zurück zu unseren erdöl
schuldenstaaten denn in washington macht
sich nun an die arbeit sie pragmatischer
weise zu rehabilitieren zumindest so
weit wie nötig die aufhebung einiger
sanktionen gegen den iran könnte das
angebot auf dem markt deutlich erhöhen
iran könnte zwei monate nach einem atom
abkommen die höchste ölproduktion
erreichen wir sprechen hier von
zusätzlichen 1,4 millionen barrel tag
für tag
hierzu müsste jedoch erst einmal eine
einigung beim atom abkommen her was auch
nicht auf die leichte schulter genommen
werden sollte wir sehen ja jetzt gerade
was für ein himmelweiter unterschied
macht ob ein schuppen staat über
atomwaffen verfügt oder nicht laut dem
eu außenbeauftragten cross apple sei
eine einigung jedoch nur noch eine
angelegenheit von tagen der westen sei
zu 95 prozent mit den forderungen
teheran einverstanden
es würde im grunde nur noch um einen
streitpunkt gehen der iran verlangt dass
eine revolutionsgarden über welche von
übrigens ein ganzes video gedreht haben
von der us terrorliste gestrichen werden
diese weiterhin strikt ab und wenn ihr
euch unser video darüber ansieht dass
ich euch natürlich verlinken werde
werdet ihr die gründe dafür genau
verstehen und er falle venezuela ist
könnte alles sogar noch komplizierter
sagen denn dort steht weit mehr als ein
stück papier im wege
die ölinfrastruktur venezuelas liegt
dermaßen lange brach und es deswegen
verfallen dass es schwierig wäre die
produktion innerhalb eines jahres auch
nur eine halbe millionen barrel zu
erhöhen doch trotz dessen unter starken
innenpolitischen kritik welche eine
annäherung an venezuela und iran in den
usa hervorgerufen hat plant das weiße
haus test mit 1 5 bis zwei millionen
barrel pro tag aus diesen quellen dieser
teil der strategie ist allerdings sicher
der ba texte und riskanteste aber die
russische invasion der ukraine hat nun
mal alle geopolitischen axiome verändert
heute weiß man in washington dass moskau
eine viel größere bedrohung darstellt
als teheran oder caracas und auf diese
bedrohung fokussiert sich die regierung
beiden jetzt voll und ganz deswegen
bringt sie doch eine dritte komponente
ihres aktionspaket ins spiel
[Musik]
praktisch jedes land verfügt über
strategische ölreserven auf die jetzt
zurückgreifen kann wenn die versorgung
aus irgendeinem grund ausfällt oder zu
stark belastet wird die usa und ihre
verbündeten vereinbaren 60 millionen
barrel erdöl aus ihren reserven frei zu
geben da die russische invasion in der
ukraine den preis in die höhe treibt nun
die strategischen reserven der usa
welche die größten der welt sind
belaufen sich derzeit auf etwa
575 millionen barrel daher können die
usa und ihre verbündeten noch viel
weiter gehen und diese reserven in noch
nie dagewesener weise nutzen um 100 bis
150 millionen barrel oder sogar mehr auf
den markt zu bringen um die spannungen
abzubauen
bis die neuen versorgungsquelle über die
wir besprochen haben in betrieb sind ja
es wäre ein riskantes unterfangen denn
eigentlich sind diese reserven dazu
gedacht dass die nationen im falle eines
versorgungsausfall doch handlungsfähig
bleiben aber abgesehen von der linderung
des aktuellen angebots defizit könnte
die maßnahme mit der verpflichtung
verbunden werden die reserven in den
nächsten jahren wieder aufzufüllen was
eine zusätzliche nachfrage garantieren
die investition in der branche weiter
ankurbeln würde daher denkt man es
handelt sich um ein risiko dass es wert
ist eingegangen zu werben
dies sind die vier massnahmen welche die
regierungen der alliierten in erwägung
ziehen und russisches öl zersetzen
darüber hinaus gibt es einen weiteren
faktor der sich als bedeutsamer erweisen
könnte die schwache lage der
chinesischen wirtschaft der krieg in der
ukraine die sanktionen und vor allem der
anstieg der rohstoff und energiepreise
könnten die weltwirtschaft bremsen dies
könnte zu einem niedrigeren öl verbrauch
als erwartet führen die energiepreise
wieder einbrechen und die russischen
kriegskassen so langfristig ganz
austrocknen lassen
[Musik]
die russische wirtschaft leidet bereits
schwer unter den bisherigen
internationalen sanktionen die
verhängung eines öl-embargos selbst wird
es nicht für raffinierte produkte gelten
würde könnte einen schacht darstellen
deshalb washington am 8 2022 den import
russischen erdöls erdgases und von kohle
in die usa verboten und arbeiten mit
hochdruck daran alle bedingungen dafür
zu schaffen dass auch alle verbündeten
ein solches verbot als bald umsetzen
können großbritannien ist bereits
nachgezogen
großbritannien will russische öl
importen bis ende 2022 auslaufen lassen
und am 25 märz kündigte auch der
deutsche wirtschaftsminister harbeck an
alle importe von erdöl und kohle aus
russland bis zum jahresende 2022 auf
null herunterzufahren
dabei soll der russische anteil der
import von erdöl von derzeit 34 prozent
bereits in den nächsten wochen auch nur
25 prozent reduziert der von kohle sogar
halbiert werden bei erdgas wird dies
etwas schwieriger aber darüber haben wir
schon vor einigen tagen ein eigenes
video gedreht der kreml versucht
unterdessen mit aussagen wie diese angst
zu schüren
es ist völlig klar dass eine ablehnung
von russischem öl katastrophale folgen
für den weltmarkt hätte der preis
besteht wäre unvorhersehbar er würde 300
dollar pro barrel tragen wenn nicht mehr
alexander nowak stellvertretende
russische ministerpräsident und
natürlich werde auch versuchen sein
ladenhüter öl china und indien an zu
drehen um doch noch etwas damit nur
verdienen ob dieser plan aufgeht ist
fraglich angesichts des maßnahmenpakets
der us-regierung wird russland kaum
markt preise erzielen können es wird
seinen wertvollen rohstoff mit viel
geringerem gewinn verfügen müssen als
geplant selbst in china hat im ersten
quartal 2022 saudi arabien russland als
öllieferant nummer eins abgelöst und das
obwohl die russen dort außerordentliche
rabatte angeboten haben dies hat vor
allem damit zu tun dass die russen ihr
bild öl in china vor allem an kleine
unabhängige raffinerien liefern welche
jedoch starke umweltverschmutzer sind
gegen diese dreckigen raffinerien geht
die regierung in peking aber schon seit
einiger zeit aus irgendwelchen gründen
stark vor und vergebt importlizenzen nur
noch andere moderne raffineriebetreiber
welche jedoch meist durch langfristige
lieferverträge an saudi arabien gebunden
sind ja irgendwie läuft der putin im
moment gar nichts in europa konnten
russischen ölfirmen ihre ware am spot
markt überhaupt nicht verkaufen weil
einfach niemand mit geboten hat und auch
wenn china im laufe des jahres doch
etwas mehr stark rabattiert des russen
nehmen sollte wird es ohnehin nicht in
der lage sein all das wohl abzunehmen
das westliche händler und raffinerien
wie die pest meiden die taten sprechen
eine eindeutige sprache und zeigen dass
es möglich ist russisches öl zu ersetzen
auch wenn die schrittweise geschehen
wird der kreml würde vom geldstrom
weitgehend abgeschnitten zumindest
würden jene profite die erst mal seine
kriegskasse benötigt verdammt weit
abschmelzen und der rest der welt müsste
dafür noch nicht mal so viel bezahlen
zur rolle chinas in diesem spiel werden
wir bald zwei weitere sehr interessante
videos veröffentlichen vergesst also
bitte nicht das abo ich danke euch und
jetzt könnt ihr mir noch die frage
beantworten meint ihr dass es den
alliierten gelingen wird ein alter die
wir zum russischen öl zu finden wird das
öl in barkow funktionieren wie immer
sind wir auf eure beiträge und
diskussionen zu diesem wichtigen thema
schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe also dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat und ihr
dabei auch etwas gelernt habt als
ergebnis bitte ein leichter folgen und
vergesst nicht dass man mit glöckchen
und keines unserer videos mehr so
verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine spende von euch mit
der er uns helfen dieses projekt
weiterzuführen die paper link dazu
findet ihr eine beschreibung oder diesem
video was gut
[Musik]